Hey,
what's up guys?
This is Tim.
I've taken off that disgusting Muskrat on my face and I am drinking some wine.
This is day four of the Vlog if this even counts.
And uh,
I am drinking this delicious wine.
It's really nice.
This is a chocolate up.
He known who are from Patagonia.
I had not had an Argentine peanut who are before.
So another long day and night of writing.
It is almost midnight and a had a very full day of writing today.
I've been working on archery also specifically blank bail practice,
which is not like dry firing with a handgun or any gun for that matter.
Uh,
all right,
so let's see some questions.
Waffles or pancakes.
Waffles,
preferably with fried chicken on a cheat day and with some Bourbon in South
Carolina.
Uh,
what does my favorite color favorite color is?
Green.
All right.
Do I recommend a multivitamin?
No,
I don't take multivitamins.
Uh,
I think that they generally include things I don't want to take like iron.
All right.
Uh,
Matthew,
what am I writing?
I'm writing a new book,
which is related to all of the best lessons,
tools,
and tricks that I've learned from all of the podcast guests,
both in the podcast and outside of the podcast.
A right morning supplements to take on a settlement on empty stomach.
Uh,
I take [inaudible],
I take,
uh,
let's see here.
What else do I take?
Msm.
I take fish oil or Krill oil,
a whole handful of things.
I mean,
literally a handful of things.
All right,
10,000 steps per day.
My take on this,
I don't think it's necessary.
It depends on what you want to do.
For some people that's very motivating,
but I'm happy to just do kettlebell swings three times a week and watch my diet
a little bit.
And,
uh,
sorry,
I'm seeing multiple questions at once and trying a monkey mind.
Have you ever started monkey mind to find you had nothing?
I have no idea what that means.
Which brand of bone?
I'm using a PSE,
carbon air,
carbon,
air,
air.
Um,
very expensive.
I also would like to use recurve,
but for my purposes right now,
I need a compound,
uh,
isle au Haut it whole life insurance,
not educated enough.
I don't have any thoughts.
Do you have any tattoos?
No,
I don't.
Why or why not?
Haven't found anything I want to permanently put in my body at this point.
I'm not averse to it.
I actually think,
uh,
for instance on women,
tattoos can sometimes be super hot,
but um,
yeah,
so I'm fine.
Anything I want to put on my body permanently,
Molly is doing much better.
Thank you for asking.
There she is.
I took off the cone of shame and I have a bit of a kind of sort of soc impromptu
macgyver thing that I've done in her foot,
which is working just fine.
Uh,
can I do have log with Seth,
which Seth are we talking about?
Seth Rogen a favorite place in South America to visit.
You know,
Patagonia is very high on the list.
I would say Columbia is great.
Chili's great for skiing.
Um,
how'd I get into archery?
I have always been interested in it,
but I'm going on my first elk hunt in Colorado in about six weeks,
so I need to get as good as possible between now and then.
And uh,
for those people who get all up in arms about hunting as I was for decades,
read the four hour chef.
Uh,
and uh,
that'll make more sense.
All right.
What's the deal with Poo air?
It's a great black tea that helps with fat loss and alertness.
So I use that in the mornings almost all the time.
Safest Way to lose 20 pounds fast is to read my article,
how to lose 20 pounds in one month.
That any exercise that's like exactly how to do it and it's free,
uh,
are right.
Uh,
as we learn a new language in short time,
just search language learning and Tim Ferriss honestly,
and you'll find a shit ton of articles.
Uh,
all right.
What's the wine?
I'll show you guys again.
It's really nice.
I'm very happy with this Chakra.
Peanut Anwar 2011 from a [inaudible] you those,
so 32,
whatever that means.
Patagonia,
Argentina
hadn't ever had peanut from Argentina.
That's very nice.
All right.
Uh,
did I get a refresher from Raul from Paris?
I did.
I did deed.
And we're also so good dude.
That's Ralph pots,
the author of vagabonding who has a writing workshop in Paris every July.
Uh,
should I get into meditating or working out first,
uh,
working out a right stranded island?
One book,
which one?
Probably the more letters to Luca alias.
She can find as a letters from a stoic or Zorba the Greek,
I dunno,
those are the first two that come to mind.
Uh,
BPC one 57.
Yes,
I have had experience,
interesting stuff.
Um,
but I've not seen a persistence of effects,
so seem to be massively effective and uh,
the issues have returned shortly thereafter,
so I'm not sure how to evaluate it.
Uh,
starting a podcast.
Any advice?
Yes.
Uh,
look up how I built a number one podcast in my name and you'll find it,
uh,
probably like 10,000 words on exactly what I recommend.
A UNC,
Yay.
Tokyo Osaka activity recommendations going next week.
Check out a blog post.
This is what I have to do on this kind of format.
Guys,
uh,
called how to cock Tokyo for less than New York City,
something like that.
And,
uh,
all sorts of good stuff in there.
All right.
I am going to answer a couple of more questions that I'm going to get out of
here.
Uh,
where would I do a bachelor party somewhere in the woods in the Pacific
northwest?
Probably.
Uh,
I want to sell everything and walk across America says Brandon,
then,
uh,
maybe you should do that.
Sounds like a great adventure.
Uh,
alright.
Beatles or the stones.
Beatles.
Uh,
what do I think about clenn and BNP?
Okay.
So for people who know,
I think Clenbuterol you can,
uh,
really,
um,
Bernet your system easily with that DMP.
You can kill yourself.
So I have no interest in it.
Very dangerous stuff.
Oh,
Rad.
Add draft a draft.
[inaudible] had a couple of questions about this.
Yeah,
I've never used it.
Don't have any thoughts on him.
Whatever we would I rather be blind or deaf.
Deaf.
Uh,
best tip for staying injury proof from training is do gymnastic strength
training and mobility work.
It seems to really bulletproof on most of your body.
Uh Oh right.
Um,
ah,
calligraphy thought so loved calligraphy.
My grandfather was a calligrapher and I did a clariphy in Japan,
in Japanese for a long time.
I love calligraphy.
I think it's a great way of developing the mind body connection with fine motor
control.
Okay.
DMT question mark.
We need a more detailed map,
but yeah.
Dimethyltryptamine interesting stuff.
Not for kids.
Uh,
any chance of for our investor book?
Probably not because it's so personalized.
I think Tony Robbins book,
uh,
what is it?
Money.
The game.
Something like that is,
is actually a very good one to pick up.
It's so highly individualized.
It's,
it's hard to write a book for the general public on investing.
Uh,
have I ever done meditation retreat?
Yes,
I have for three days.
I'm doing a 10 day silent retreat in the not too distant future.
All right.
Hello?
From Brazil one nudge.
It must be a,
actually,
I guess it's about the same time as it is here about midnight.
So I've goodnight,
uh,
if I had 200 pounds to lose,
where would I start?
David?
I would,
uh,
look up how to lose a hundred pounds on the slow carb diet,
which has a couple of real examples of people who have lost 140,
150 yet,
and I've met people who've lost 200 pounds.
So that's where I would start.
Where should I go eat dinner in SF right now?
Brooke,
you should go to central kitchen,
uh,
where you could go if you want to be really fancy,
go to [inaudible].
That's expensive.
You may not get a table.
Do I still hang out with Neil?
Yes they do.
If we're talking about Neil Strauss,
uh,
one possible,
he's got a new kid,
so he's a busy,
busy,
busy man.
Uh,
how,
Yay.
Okay.
I want to quit the job I hate and do something else but scared that if I feel it
will push me further back.
Any advice in 27 years old?
Yes.
Get the four hour workweek.
Buy It on kindle.
It's like nine bucks,
maybe less and read.
I think it's chapter two.
Fear setting.
That is what you need to do.
All right.
Uh,
bear with me.
Bear with me.
What am I most grateful for my life right now?
Right now it's a chance to talk to you guys and the incredibly comfortable bed
that is waiting for me and my pooch.
After I send off an email and finish my boss one.
So on that point I'm gonna let you guys go,
but um,
if you're enjoying these,
these logs,
let me know cause uh,
this is definitely a labor of love late night thing and can see what's going on.
So thanks for hanging out guys.
Hope you enjoy and I'll talk to you soon.
Bye.
Thanks so much for watching guys and be sure to consider signing up for my email
newsletter by clicking on email,
a newsletter because I share private Q and A's exclusive content,
awesome things like five bullet Fridays,
which is the five coolest things I've discovered in a given week exclusively via
email.
And that's for the die hard.
That's for the people who really want the main line of usefulness and how to,
and uh,
to really ride along with me as I learn and discover the most useful things that
I find.
So check it out,
email newsletter,
click on it,
and please let me know what you would like more of in terms of video,
in terms of audio.
I will try to make it for you.
So let me know in the comments and thank you again for watching.